pourquoi les inuits ne sont pas inclus
dans les premières nations du canada
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6
ministre amon depuis cette semaine je
réponds à la question de suzy les
premières nations et les inuit
ce sont des groupes qui sont très
distincts les uns des autres comme les
métis le sont aussi mais ce sont trois
groupes autochtones reconnus avec des
droits autochtones qui sont les mêmes
simplement quand il ya eu la première et
ça c'est les théories de migration des
premiers peuples
quant à lui la première migration mais
les premières nations seraient passés
par le détroit de béring ce sera encore
à confirmer mais il serait passé par le
détroit de béring aurait suivi justement
là où les glaciers avait fondu et il se
serait répandu partout en amérique aux
etats-unis au canada en amérique du sud
à partir de cette route là le faut pas
oublier qu'on parlait de glaciers qui
font honte et dire que le pont ne
m'aurait pas en glace et une pas mal pas
mal bien endurci qu'en quelques années
plus tard quelques années quelques
milliers d'années plus tard ce qu'une
loi les inuits eux mêmes ont commencé à
faire
déplacement sur leucate polaire non non
là on parle d'environ 2000 a pu se
déplacer autour du grand nom c'est pour
ça qu'on retrouve des nations escaliers
autres dans le nord de la russie dans le
nord de la norvège au groenland et au
québec au canada il ya des groupes qui
sont installés dans quatre territoires
très distincts qu'on nomme le nunavut le
nunavik le inovi alouettes et le
nunatsiavut quitte au labrador
ck territoire la représentent des
groupes il nous est très distincts mais
se voit reconnaître le chemin qui a été
utilisée par les nations inuits
donc quand on a fait la loi sur les
indiens on parlait des premières nations
des peuples étaient plus au sud
et c'est pour ça que cette loi là en
fait une distinction très claire entre
premières nations et les inuits dans le
droit canadien
cependant quand dans les années 50 on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait aussi
besoin d'inclure le grand nord dans nos
enjeux canadien politique là les
premières les les peuples inuit ont été
inclus mais je dirais que les lits
ils ont pas eu la loi sur les indiens -
un équivalent ce qui faisait que eux
c'étaient pas des chefs c'était des
mères mais il avait des reconnaissances
sur leur territoire donc tu peux
comprendre que en étant distincts deux
territoires distincts d'histoire
distinct de la langue aussi on ne peut
pas inclure les inuit dans les indiens
aussi facilement que ça avait été fait
avec toutes les premières nations
alors aujourd'hui encore on voit que les
inuits et les programmations des
injections communs liés aux peuples
autochtones mais ont des enjeux qui sont
très différent lié au fait qu'ils sont
eux les inuits et nous des premières
nations
alors c'est une histoire qui est très
compliqué et très longue je t'invite à
petit intéressés et à lire de plus en
plus sur l'historique des inuits car est
extrêmement intéressante et
culturellement très riche
alors n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions n'hésitez pas à demander des
détails justement sur cet historique là
et ne s'était pas surtout à partager des
vidéos sur cette nouvelle semaine